what do you think of the pro fat
movement now it's very interesting the
fat activism
i mean i
yeah i've been as people who've
struggled with our weight it's
interesting to see now
it's gone the other way where fat people
are like threatening people on social
media
330 pounds and no one should have been
promoting me
i
i was
disgusting
and should have been shot
i should have been
hunted down and shot i was not i was
a animal
i should have gotten help someone should
have
someone should have gotten a net
and [ __ ]
put me in a cage and help me
[Laughter]
but there's a movement now well i needed
movement i needed a lot of movement
because i was dying yeah okay there's a
movement to celebrate
i should have not been celebrated i had
i had
rashes yes
i was not okay
but
what has happened
you know what i mean like what has
happened where
it it's gone to a place
where
there is a celebration
of
that type of behavior
well i think that no i don't think
fat people should be
victimized or treated like [ __ ] no but
no one thinks that
of course not but we've gone to in such
an extreme
place i have a lot of fat professionals
my agent is fat and they're very
distracted they're fat
my tour is booked
if you look at the way my tour is booked
it's booked in towns with steakhouses so
that my agent can come i have a fat
assistant she's lovely
but she's distracted because they're
always thinking about eating i'm
surprised your tour isn't all at like
burger kings yeah no my tour is
literally routed around the openings of
steakhouses
and but
you know
it is a distracting thing like i'm
trying to lose weight it's hard
do they always have food in their mouths
when you're talking to them they're
chewing they're crunching ladies are
they like moving from there
they crunch
they crunch things they have little
vittles that they have
they've got food everywhere like you
know it's distracting it's like again
it's a compulsion i know you don't have
to tell me i'm an animal i [ __ ] my face
with food i don't even chew you know
what it is i know so to me the idea that
that's become a celebrated part of our
society it's not okay it's not okay
the mukbangs online you've seen them
people just eat people watching
i mean did you see nick avocado's video
where the woman was getting stabbed yeah
i sent that cherry please bring that up
someone's getting stabbed there's a
woman in an apartment building getting
stabbed
and i don't know if you even know who
this guy is this guy
all he does is eat online and he
eats these crazy things and he's just
kind of killing himself
online
every day he's pretty popular and he's
very pot people want to watch him kill
himself with food this is a deeply
disturbed society now i want you to
listen to this because this is literally
true
someone's getting stabbed to death in
the apartment next door and they notice
it and they keep eating watch this
okay they taste like this but
you know oh you hear the screams grease
here
play it again and i want you to listen
for the screams you can hear him okay
you can literally hear the screams
okay they taste like this but
you know oh
i mean you hear somebody in the
background
so somebody's you know that he just made
me homophobic and i'm married to a woman
yeah yeah yeah like i want to suck dick
after watching that yeah yeah
it's so disturbing because there's
people
millions of them watching
this type of stuff it's it's
there's something that the the
internet's unlocked which is really
terrible
that's so disturbing watching him eat
like that yeah it's really bad
it's i yeah it's not good so he's really
popular he's very popular i've watched a
lot of his stuff he just eats for hours
he goes crazy now why do you watch it
you sick [ __ ] i i don't really know why
when you're really hungry and you want
fast food late at night if you just
watch him eat a bunch of tacos from
jack-in-the-box or something uh soothing
about it there's something and it's also
kind of funny and morbid and is he just
talking while he's eating yeah he tells
he has little anecdotes and he has his
boyfriend orlan i think olin or orland
and they do cooking recipes too so
they'll cook ramen noodles with cheese
and eat those and show you recipes and
he'll go around target in a rascal
scooter and do little skits and stuff so
this is where we are this is a and
they're famous they're famous yeah yeah
and i'm going to do six shows at the
[ __ ]
chuckle bunnies yeah
yeah well you know
but this is really disturbing stuff and
your mother is a therapist probably is
she probably has just some very
interesting uh you know thoughts and
ideas about
how it got this bad